[Aplausos]
[Música]
méxico se ha puesto de moda en hollywood
mientras está sigue empeñado en
construir el muro los directores de cine
mexicanos han ganado cinco de los
últimos seis oscar es al mejor director
pero todo ese talento que tienen los
mexicanos para el mundo del cine
desaparece cuando hablamos de la
política
[Música]
hace un año os contábamos cómo el país
de guillermo del toro había dicho adiós
a décadas de bipartidismo y sobre todo
de corrupción para que os hagáis una
idea el anterior presidente enrique peña
nieto- dejó el cargo con los peores
índices de popularidad que ha tenido
nunca un presidente mexicano y así es
como empezó la presidencia de andrés
manuel lópez obrador
la nueva rockstar de la izquierda
mexicana se trata del primer presidente
que ha obtenido el respaldo de 30
millones de votos una victoria
aplastante y todo esto sin contar con el
apoyo de ninguno de los dos grandes
partidos
[Música]
los mexicanos que habían un cambio
radical y eso es exactamente lo que
hablo ha prometido y la pregunta es
pues lo cierto es que si las cosas están
cambiando en méxico pero están cambiando
a peor de crecer a más de 12 por ciento
se ha pasado a previsiones que sitúan el
crecimiento para el año 2019 en apenas
0,2 por ciento si amigos de visual
política todo apunta a que méxico va a
sufrir una crisis importante y ya sé lo
que me vais a decir a ver fonseca
este hombre no lleva ni un año
gobernando en mexico ya le vas a echar
en cara a todo lo que está pasando en la
economía del país es realmente culpa
suya hoy vamos a responder a estas
preguntas pero antes vamos a ver un poco
de historia
y el renacido gonzález iñárritu ganó su
segundo oscar con el renacido pero si
hay un renacido de verdad en méxico ese
es amlo empezó en uno de esos dos
grandes partidos mexicanos el partido
revolucionario institucional lo que
sería el centroizquierda pero enseguida
se dio cuenta de que eso de
revolucionario institucional a la vez es
como un poco raro así que creó su propio
partido un partido verdaderamente de
izquierdas y así es como ganó su primer
gran logro la alcaldía de ciudad de
méxico
dirigir la capital del país supuso el
trampolín definitivo para amlo
[Música]
candidato a la presidencia de la
república en 2006 sin embargo se quedó a
250 mil votos para ganar las elecciones
en ese momento es cuando él lópez
obrador promovió todo tipo de protestas
los suyos le aclamaron como presidente
legítimo pero tuvo que esperar a las
elecciones de 2012 para repetir su
candidatura y esta vez se quedó aún más
lejos de ocupar la residencia de los
pinos cada vez se parecía más a un
cadáver político que a otra cosa y en
ese momento cuando nadie apostaba por él
habló resurgió de las cenizas con un
nuevo partido político el movimiento
para la regeneración nacional más
conocido como morena su programa podría
resumirse en acabar con todo lo que
habían hecho los anteriores gobiernos y
empezar desde cero con esta fórmula
arrasó en las elecciones y lo cierto es
que no ha defraudado
[Música]
veréis en el sistema político de méxico
hay que esperar cinco meses desde que un
candidato gana las elecciones hasta que
jura el cargo pues bien durante esos
cinco meses
amlo no creáis que ha estado esperando
de brazos cruzados en ese tiempo se ha
dedicado a organizar referéndums tu idea
era que nada más empezar a gobernar ya
tendría una serie de políticas listas
para ejecutar y con el respaldo de los
ciudadanos y diréis oye pues no es mala
idea verdad vamos a ver que en suiza o
liechtenstein les encanta hacer este
tipo de cosas y no parece que les vaya
mal dónde está el problema con hacer
referéndums y si tenéis razón el
problema es que estos referéndums no
estaban organizados por el instituto
electoral sino por el propio partido de
anv lo habéis oído bien para que os
hagáis una idea sólo uno de cada cinco
municipios tenía urnas y como os podéis
imaginar la limpieza del proceso
electoral era saber cómo decirlo mejor
mirad esta noticia
hasta cuatro veces pudo votar una misma
persona en consulta sobre el nuevo
aeropuerto pero aquí determinada cosa
veréis cuando hablamos de referéndums el
modo en el que redactamos la pregunta
puede ser determinante para el resultado
que vamos a obtener en otras palabras
cambiando la pregunta puede es
básicamente conseguir la respuesta que
quieras por ejemplo vamos a imaginar que
yo os pregunto así sin entrar en
detalles queréis que doblemos la pensión
mensual para las personas mayores o por
ejemplo queréis becas para los
estudiantes de bachillerato seguro que
todos votaría es que sí pues exactamente
estas han sido las preguntas de los
referéndums de morena y como os podéis
imaginar todos estos referéndums han
tenido un 90 por ciento de síes y si es
verdad ninguno de estos referéndum será
vinculante pero a amlo le han venido de
perlas para justificar todas sus
actuaciones a fin de cuentas el que ha
consultado al pueblo
y qué tipo de medidas está haciendo
ángulo pues aquí tenemos un ejemplo
cancelar la construcción del nuevo
aeropuerto de ciudad de méxico hablamos
de un proyecto de 13.000 millones de
dólares en el que ya se habían gastado
los primeros cinco mil es decir que
podríamos decir que el gobierno de
méxico acaba de tirar por la borda cinco
mil millones de dólares y diréis porque
lo ha hecho pues muy fácil convocó uno
de estos referéndums en el que votó el 1
por ciento de la población y en el que
la pregunta la habían redactado sus
propios partidarios pues bien para ambos
eso ya es razón más que suficiente
veréis todos los políticos toman muchas
decisiones a partir de encuestas en el
fondo estos referéndums funcionarían
como una encuesta más sin validez
jurídica aunque bueno habló no piensa lo
mismo vamos a gobernar
preguntándole a la gente
dicen que para equivocarse lo mejor es
presentar una democracia
de 23 de nuevo el problema no es hacer
referéndums es más la ley mexicana
contempla la opción de hacer consultas
populares pero claro hay que tener una
autoridad independiente y sobre todo es
necesario que haya una mayoría
cualificada de votantes para que el
resultado tenga validez jurídica para
que os hagáis una idea hasta este año
2019 la ley decía que para que un
referéndum fuera realmente vinculante
hacía falta un mínimo del 40 por ciento
de participación pues bien el partido de
anv lo acabo de cambiar esa ley para que
ahora baste con un 25 por ciento un 25
por ciento de participación son unos 20
millones de mexicanos en las consultas
que organizó a amlo antes de ser
investido como presidente apenas
participó un millón en otras palabras
que la democracia directa que propone
hablo es bastante discutible pero
esperad un momento porque todavía no
hemos terminado a estas alturas o
estaréis preguntando pero que está
haciendo lópez obrador aparte de
organizar consultas pues ahora mismo lo
vamos a ver
[Música]
a la presidencia de amlo se puede
resumir en un gesto simbólico ha
decidido no trasladar su residencia al
palacio de los pinos muchos pensaréis
así me gusta por fin un político que
huye de los lujos al más puro estilo de
pepe mujica en uruguay verdad el
problema es que donde creéis que está
viviendo hablo en este momento pues nada
más y nada menos que era el palacio
nacional es decir que simplemente ha
cambiado un palacio por otro y para que
han quedado los pinos pues se ha abierto
al público como recinto cultural de
hecho su primer gran evento fue
proyectar roma la película de cuarón y
por supuesto no cobrar entrada porque
era un evento público y atentos porque
en este caso sí que se han tomado en
serio la transparencia
cultura deberá informar sobre cuánto se
gastó en palomitas y ponche durante la
proyección de roma' en los pinos habéis
oído bien que haber de nuevo proyectar
roma en el palacio de los pinos no es
nada malo tampoco es algo bueno lo que
sí tiene consecuencias en la economía y
sí que espanta los inversores
internacionales son esos bandazos y esos
cambios de opinión tan repentinos que
está teniendo como por ejemplo el de
cancelar la construcción del aeropuerto
méxico se desploma a 8 posiciones en
ranking de inversión extranjera directa
méxico cayó a la última posición del
ranking elaborado por haití cornyn tras
décadas de monopolio estatal la
petrolera mexicana pemex se había
convertido en un auténtico pozo de
corrupción tenían unas deudas nacho vida
dianas y de no ser por el aval del
estado mexicano se habrían ido a la
ruina que hizo peña nieto- puedes abrir
el mercado a la inversión extranjera
atraer a compañías de fuera de mexico
para subastar la explotación de campos
petroleros el objetivo era que ya que
pemex no podía explotar todos los campos
petroleros del país permitir que lo
hicieran otras empresas y así por lo
menos pueden generar algo más de riqueza
pues bien el gobierno de amlo ya ha
dicho que los próximos tres años no va a
hacer ninguna subasta y luego está el
tema del gasolinazo resulta que méxico
le tiene que comprar el 70 por ciento de
la gasolina que consume a eeuu y diréis
por qué pues porque la producción de
pemex va de mal en peor y cuál es la
solución mágica que ha planteado hablo
pues nada más y nada menos que construir
una nueva refinería ahora
con pemex sin recursos y sin dinero que
llegue de inversión extranjera de dónde
va a salir el dinero
pues buena pregunta
[Música]
el gobierno de méxico asumirá con pemex
la construcción de una nueva refinería
el anuncio levanta dudas levanta dudas
porque ninguna de las compañías que
participó en la licitación del proyecto
considera que las condiciones de obra
son realistas en 2022 veremos si las
empresas o el gobierno tenían la razón
de lo que no hay dudas es de como la
obsesión de amlo ha sido dar marcha
atrás a todas las reformas aunque fueran
positivas es el caso de la reforma
educativa veréis méxico tiene un
problema con los privilegios de los
sindicatos educativos en casi todos los
países democráticos los profesores de
escuela pública tienen que pasar un
examen para obtener su puesto de trabajo
por ejemplo este es el sistema que
tenemos en españa ocurre en
prácticamente todos los países menos en
mexico en este caso son los sindicatos
quienes contratan a los maestros y el
puesto de profesor es algo que se puede
vender o incluso heredar una de las
reformas de peña nieto fue intentar
implementar un sistema de educación
pública más parecido al de españa o al
de prácticamente cualquier
y así es como surgieron las protestas
más violentas que os podéis imaginar
[Música]
y miles de docentes optaron por
jubilarse antes de tener que hacer el
examen también hay más de mil profesores
que fueron expulsados de las aulas tras
no superar por tres veces la evaluación
y ser reubicados en puestos
administrativos pero todo esto ya es
historia y porque es historia pues
porque uno de los grupos que más apoyo a
hablo en las elecciones fueron estos
sindicatos de profesores así que lo
primero que ha hecho lópez obrador ha
sido dar marcha atrás con las reformas
de nuevo los profesores mexicanos
seguirán disfrutando de unos privilegios
prácticamente únicos en el mundo y los
niños mexicanos volverán a tener
profesores que ni siquiera han tenido
que demostrar que saben lo que
supuestamente van a enseñarlo
[Música]
pero sin duda alguna lo más polémico de
toda su gestión ha sido la guerra contra
el narcotráfico resulta que cuando la
derecha panista gobernaba en mexico se
aprobó una ley para que el ejército
pudiera luchar contra los narcos
claramente esta medida sólo ha servido
para empeorar la situación en los
últimos 12 años méxico ha tenido más de
250.000 muertes relacionadas
directamente con el narcotráfico y jiang
lo prometió en campaña que acabaría con
esta guerra
y diréis qué es lo que ha hecho pues
ahora en lugar de desplegar al ejército
se utiliza a la nueva guardia nacional
integrada totalmente por militares y
liderada por un general experto en
guerra contra narcotráfico en otras
palabras que todo cambia para que todo
sigue igual podemos decir que amlo ha
perpetuado la presencia militar en las
calles haciendo el trabajo de la policía
y así son los cambiazos de amlo su
gobierno ha acabado con muchos programas
sociales para reemplazarlos por otros
los creados por el mismo y algo parecido
ha pasado con el aeropuerto de méxico
todo el dinero que se ha ahorrado el
estado al parar las obras lleva a gastar
en una línea de trenes el llamado tren
maya la idea es que este tren potencie
el desarrollo del sureste de méxico pero
el proyecto tiene bastantes comillas
y organizaciones mayas exigen a amlo
detener la construcción del tren maya lo
cierto es que desde el punto de vista
económico no está del todo claro que
este tren vaya a generar puestos de
trabajo a fin de cuentas hablamos de una
de las zonas más pobres del país donde
apenas hay fábricas que produzcan bienes
para transportar lo que sí parece mucho
más claro es el impacto ecológico por el
momento el proyecto no tiene aprobado
ningún estudio de impacto ambiental pero
nada de esto detiene al gobierno a
seguir intentándolo y de dónde saldrá el
dinero pues de nuevo
buena pregunta no lo sabemos por el
momento los inversores extranjeros están
saliendo del país y el crecimiento
económico va de mal en peor en cualquier
caso todavía falta tiempo para ver cómo
terminará la administración de amlo en
el momento en el que hacemos este vídeo
ni siquiera ha terminado su primer año
así que ahora la pregunta es para
vosotros creéis que el gobierno de amlo
será capaz de evitar una recesión en
méxico o creéis que el dinero que está
huyendo del país nunca volverá podeis
dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios y como siempre no olvidéis
que sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las
semanas así que suscribimos a visual
político y dadle a la campanita para no
perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones os ha gustado este vídeo
dadle a like y nos vemos en el próximo
un abrazo y hasta pronto
[Música]